THEN THE REST OF IT.
THAT’S IT FOR US.
SEAN HANNITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: THANK YOU, TUCKER.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
IN LESS THAN THREE MONTHS,
YOU’RE THE ULTIMATE JURY AND YOU
WILL MAKE THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
DECISION IN OUR LIFETIME,
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR KIDS AND
GRANDKIDS.
AMERICA, THE WORLD, FREEDOM,
LIBERTY, CAPITALISM VERSUS
LIBERTY-CRUSHING SOCIALISM.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS IN 90 DAYS.
DO YOU WANT JOE BIDEN, THE EVER
CONFUSED ONE, BOLSHEVIK BERNIE,
AOC, BOZO, SCHUMER, PELOSI
RUNNING THE COUNTRY?
WELL, I DO NOT.
RONALD REAGAN WARNED THAT THIS
NATION -- HE WARNED US ALL.
FREEDOM IS BUT ONE GENERATION
AWAY FROM EXTINCTION.
WE OWE IT TO HER KIDS AND
GRANDKIDS DID NOT TO BE THAT
GENERATION THAT LETS IT BECOME
EXTINCT.
EARLIER TODAY, BIDEN HAD YET
ANOTHER COMPLETE MELTDOWN WHILE
TRYING TO ANSWER A SIMPLE
QUESTION ABOUT HIS COGNITIVE
ABILITIES THAT HE BRAGS SO MUCH
ABOUT PASSING THE TEST, I TAKE
THEM ALL THE TIME.
AT THAT FULL TAPE IS COMING UP
BUT WE WILL ASK IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS FITNESS FOR
OFFICE THAT THE MEDIA MOB, THEY
TALK ABOUT PRIVATELY.
DEMOCRATS TALK ABOUT PRIVATELY,
BUT NEVER PUBLICLY.
ALSO, MAJOR BREAKING NEWS OUT OF
THE SWAMP, SALLY YATES WAS JUST
GRILLED BY THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHERE SHE ACCUSED
MR. HIGHER HONOR HIMSELF OF
GOING ROGUE AND WAS FORCED TO
ADMIT THAT THE PHIS APPLICATIONS
THAT SHE SIGNED, THE ONES THAT
SAY VERIFIED, WERE FRAUDULENT.
AND BY THE WAY, KNOWING WHAT SHE
NOW KNOWS, SHE NEVER WOULD’VE
SIGNED THEM.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM WITH THAT
UPDATE.
ALSO TONIGHT, PANIC HAS SAID AND
AMONG DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA
MOB.
WE’RE GOING TO ANALYZE THE
LATEST INSANE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ALL STRAIGHT AHEAD.
WE MUST ASK THE OBVIOUS
QUESTION.
THE MEDIA MOB, THE DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE AVOIDING IT LIKE THE
PLAGUE.
NOW, I KNOW FOR A FACT,
PRIVATELY, THEY ARE SCARED TO
DEATH ABOUT THIS.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH JOE BIDEN?
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH JOE BIDEN?
THE QUESTION IS THIS: DOES THIS
77-YEAR-OLD MAN REALLY HAVE THE
STAMINA, THE STRENGTH, THE
MENTAL ACUITY, MENTAL ALERTNESS
TO SERVE IN THE TOUGHEST, MOST
DEMANDING JOB ON EARTH?
IN 1984, SIMILAR QUESTIONS WERE
POSED TO 73-YEAR-OLD
PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN.
THAT WAS DURING HIS REELECTION
CAMPAIGN AND HERE’S HOW REAGAN
FAMOUSLY RESPONDED.
>> I WILL NOT MAKE AGE AN ISSUE
OF THIS CAMPAIGN.
I’M NOT GOING TO EXPLOIT FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES MY OPPONENT’S
YOUTH AND INEXPERIENCE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Sean: THAT RACE ENDED RIGHT
THERE.
49 STATE A SUITE BY
RONALD REAGAN PURITY SO MUCH
DIFFERENT RESPONSE FROM
JOE BIDEN.
HERE’S HIS RESPONSE.
AGAIN, WE SEE IT OFTEN,
COMPLETELY INCOHERENT.
ACTUALLY A LITTLE HARD TO WATCH.
ACTUALLY LIKE BARKING AT A
REPORTER.
IT’S NOT THE FIRST TIME HE’S
DONE THIS.
HE LOSES HIS TRAIN OF THOUGHT.
HE BECAME TOTALLY, COMPLETELY
AND UTTERLY CONFUSED.
FAIRLY COMMON OCCURRENCE WITH
JOE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PLEASE CLARIFY, SPECIFICALLY,
HAVE YOU TAKEN A COGNITIVE --
>> NO, I HAVEN’T TAKEN A TEST.
WHY THE HELL WHAT I TAKE A TEST?
COME ON, MAN FEAR THAT IS LIKE
SAYING YOU COME UP FOR THE
PROGRAM YOU’RE TAKING A TEST
WHETHER YOU ARE TAKING COCAINE
OR NOT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO BRAGS ABOUT
HIS TEST AND MAKES YOU ARE -- AN
ISSUE FOR VOTERS?
>> [LAUGHS]
WELL, IF HE CAN’T FIGURE OUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN ELEPHANT
AND A LION, I DON’T KNOW WHAT
THE HELL HE IS TALKING ABOUT.
DID YOU WATCH THAT?
COME ON, MAN.
I KNOW YOU’RE TRYING TO GOAD ME
BUT I’M SO FORWARD LOOKING
HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO SIT
WITH THE PRESIDENT, OR STAND
WITH THE PRESIDENT IN THE
DEBATES.
THERE IS GOING TO BE PLENTY OF
TIME.
AND BY THE WAY, AS I JOKE WITH
HIM, I SHOULDN’T SAY IT.
I’M GOING TO SAY SOMETHING I
PROBABLY SHOULDN’T SAY.
ANYWAY, I AM VERY WILLING TO
LEAD THE AMERICAN PUBLIC JUDGE
MY PHYSICAL AND MENTAL -- MY
PHYSICAL AS WELL AS MY MENTAL
FITNESS, TOO, YOU KNOW, MAKE A
JUDGMENT ABOUT WHO I AM.
>> Sean: OKAY.
COME ON, MAN!
A COCAINE TEST?
ARE YOU A JUNKIE?
AN ELEPHANT AND A LION?
WHAT DID WE JUST WATCH?
THIS IS JUST SIMPLE NOT NORMAL
OR APPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR.
APPARENTLY BIDEN EVEN FORGOT
THAT JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO,
REMEMBER?
HE WAS ACTUALLY TELLING
REPORTERS AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT HE WAS CONSTANTLY
TESTED FOR COGNITIVE DECLINE.
OCCASIONALLY, OF COURSE WE WILL
ADMIT EVERYONE GETS WORDS MESSED
UP HERE THERE BUT THIS IS NOW A
DAILY OCCURRENCE FOR JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN, THIS IS SERIOUS, AS
CONFUSED AS HE IS, HE IS RUNNING
FOR THE MOST IMPORTANT, THE
HARDEST, THE TOUGHEST, THE MOST
DIFFICULT JOB IN THE FREE WORLD.
HE WANTS TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
OUR COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
IF HE’S EVER ELECTED, HIS FINGER
WILL BE ON THAT A NUCLEAR
BUTTON.
SO, OBVIOUSLY, MENTAL ACUITY,
ALERTNESS IS VERY IMPORTANT, AND
YET BIDEN SEEMS TO STRUGGLE EVEN
NUMEROUS TIMES ON THIS SHOW.
YOU THINK I’M OVER STATING THE
FACTS?
WE’LL LET YOU DECIDE TONIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> POOR KIDS ARE JUST AS BRIGHT
AND JUST AS TALENTED AS WHITE
KIDS.
>> WHY IN GOD’S NAME SHOULD
SOMEONE WHO IS CLIPPING COUPONS
IN THE STOCK MARKET MAKE IN FACT
PAY A LOWER TAX RATE THAN
SOMEONE WHO IN FACT IS, LIKE I
SAID, A SCHOOLTEACHER AND A
FIREFIGHTER?
>> LOOK, TOMORROW’S SUPERSTARS,
SERIOUSLY, AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL.
I TELL YOU WHAT, I’M RUSHING
AHEAD, AREN’T I?
>> WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT.
ALL MEN AND WOMEN CREATED BY --
OH, YOU KNOW THE THING.
>> Sean: JOE, ENDOWED BY THE
CREATOR OF EVERYTHING.
ADJUST THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE, AND BY THE WAY, IT
WAS SUPER TUESDAY, NOT SUPER
THURSDAY.
CLIPPING COUPONS IN THE STOCK
MARKET?
WHAT DOES THAT EVEN MEAN?
AND THE CONFUSION DOESN’T STOP
THERE.
I’M GOING TO TELL YOU, EVEN WHAT
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW YOU
TONIGHT, WOW IS JUST A SMALL
SAMPLING.
WE COULD GO ON FOR THE WHOLE
HOUR.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DONALD TRUMP DOES POSE
SENSE -- IT’S NOT HYPOTHETICAL.
>> I WANT TO BE CLEAR, I’M NOT
GOING NUTS.
>> ALL RIGHT, JACK, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
IT’S CHRIS, BUT ALL RIGHT.
>> I JUST DID CHRIS.
>> MY SON, MY DECEASED SON WAS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES AND BEFORE THAT HE
WAS A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR IN ONE
OF THE LARGEST OFFICES IN THE
COUNTRY.
IN PHILADELPHIA.
>> Sean: A LITTLE FACT-CHECK,
JOE SON WAS NEVER THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WHAT IS HE TALKING ABOUT?
SADLY, JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
HERE ARE MORE DEEPLY TROUBLING
EXAMPLES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF YOU AGREE WITH ME, GO TO
JOE 30330.
>> WE CHOOSE TRUTH OVER FACTS!
>> PLAY THE RADIO, MAKE SURE THE
TELEVISION -- EXCUSE ME, MAKE
SURE YOU HAVE THE RECORD PLAYER
ON AT NIGHT, THE PHONE.
MAKE SURE THE KIDS HEAR WORDS.
>> 150 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
KILLED SINCE 2007 WHEN BERNIE
VOTED TO EXEMPT THE GUN
MANUFACTURERS FROM LIABILITY.
MORE THAN ALL THE WARS,
INCLUDING VIETNAM, FROM THAT
POINT ON.
CARNAGE ON OUR STREETS.
>> Sean: TRUTH OVER FACTS!
150 MILLION PEOPLE KILLED FROM
GUN VIOLENCE.
THAT WOULD BE ALMOST HALF THE
COUNTRY.
TONIGHT, IT’S NOT JUST THE
CONFUSION, THE FORGETFULNESS,
THE GAFFES THAT YOU SHOULD WORRY
ABOUT.
IT’S ALSO VERY STRENGTH
ASSOCIATED FITS OF RAGE.
HE JUST SCREAMED AT THAT
"CBS NEWS" REPORTER, ASKED IF HE
WAS A JUNKIE AND NEEDED A
COCAINE TEST AND THIS IS IN THE
FIRST TIME JOE IMPLODED IN FRONT
OF A CAMERA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I AGREED WITH THE GREAT JOB
SHE DID, AND I WENT ON THE FLOOR
AND GOT YOU VOTES.
I GOT VOTES FOR THAT BILL!
I CONVINCE PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR
IT, SO LET’S GET THOSE THINGS
STRAIGHT TOO.
SPEAK OF THE NOVEMBER CAUCUS,
NO, YOU HAVEN’T.
YOU ARE A LION, DOG FACED PONY
SOLDIER.
YOU SAID YOU ARE BUT NOW YOU GOT
TO BE HONEST.
>> I SET UP MY SON TO WORK IN AN
OIL COMPANY.
ISN’T THAT WHAT YOU SAID?
AT YOUR WORDS STRAIGHT, JACK.
LET’S DO PUSH-UPS TOGETHER,
LET’S DO WHATEVER YOU WANT TO DO
DO.
>> [BLEEP] >> Sean: THESE ARE
THE TYPES
OF THINGS TERRY McAULIFFE WAS
REFERRING TO WHEN HE SAID I’M
PERFECTLY FINE IF JOE BIDEN
STAYS IN HIS BASEMENT, BUNKER
UNTIL ELECTION DAY.
LET’S STATE SOME FACTS.
JOE BIDEN LOSES HIS TRAIN OF
THOUGHT OFTEN.
HE MAKES HIS NUMBERS UP OFTEN.
HE STRUGGLES TO REMEMBER CERTAIN
WORDS.
AT TIMES, HE DOESN’T EVEN KNOW
WHAT DAY OF THE WEEK IT IS, WHAT
STATE HE IS AN END WHAT OFFICE
HE IS EVEN RUNNING FOR.
HE’S EXPERIENCING FREQUENT BOUTS
OF IRRITABILITY, ANGER,
CONFUSION.
I’M NOT A DOCTOR, I DON’T KNOW
WHAT’S GOING ON WITH BIDEN, BUT
IT’S OBVIOUS THAT SOMETHING IS
OFF.
A VERY OFF.
AND EVEN THOUGH HE BARELY LEAVES
HIS BASEMENT BUNKER, HE LOOKS
EXHAUSTED.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE NEEDS A HOT
COCOA AND A LITTLE NAP EVERY
DAY.
GIVEN WHAT WE SAY, IT WOULDN’T
BE A GOOD IDEA FOR HIM TO TAKE
THAT COGNITIVE TEST.
BY THE WAY, AA, COMPREHENSIVE
PHYSICAL EXAM, SHARE THE RESULTS
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALREADY DONE
THAT AND MORE.
IT’S AN HONEST QUESTION AT THIS
POINT, AND BEFORE EARLY VOTING
STARTS, WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE AN ANSWER.
RECENTLY THE PRESIDENT
ENCOURAGED BIDEN TO TAKE THE
TEST.
HE SAT DOWN WITH AN INTERVIEW
WITH DR. SIEGEL FROM OUR MEDICAL
AID TEAM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JOE SHOULD TAKE THAT TEST
BECAUSE SOMETHING IS GOING ON,
AND I SAY THIS WITH RESPECT.
IT WILL PROBABLY HAPPEN TO ALL
OF US, RIGHT?
YOU KNOW, IT’S GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY THAT’S
SHARP.
IF THIS PERSON ISN’T SHARP,
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU,
PRESIDENT XI ISN’T SHARP.
PRESIDENT PUTIN IS SHARP.
YOU DON’T HAVE ANY NONSHARP